in front of miami lounge florida tag
seven six alpha whiskey india quebec
displayed on a mercedes-benz suv
on an octaves
[Music]
yeah i'm always doing it from the graves
that's all right hey the reason i'm
stopping you were speeding on this road
yeah you're going pretty fast you know
what the speed limit is
hello bro 45.
45 man yeah you also failed to maintain
your lane when i passed you yeah really
yeah you're passing it all right sorry
my man appreciate it hey whose vehicle
is this
that's yours let me let me let me go
and i'll be like i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry
what are you doing out this way sir hey
what are you doing out this way like
party coming to miami lounge yeah okay
all right you good you can hold that
give me a second all right just stay in
the car
i i just give you i just give you the
insurance yeah that's fine yeah you want
one of the the the ruiz race no you're
good just hold it right now man thank
you i'll be back with you
so want somewhere now 10 27 out of
florida
oscar
four one 253-540-90412
zero florida
careful
116 county caniners
want somebody i'll be on fields you can
start my coat sudden parking lot of
miami lounge
foreign
honey
up
this
hey man step out real quick and talk to
me back here man all right
you can close the door close it up
stand right here for me yeah
right there
got anything to drink tonight no no
alcohol
you know you know i'm
i'm fighting my man
who's riding with you yeah who's in the
car with him like that all right so
you've been drinking meat no
i just smell alcohol in the car really
yeah
oh you had anything to drink tonight
yeah but
i'm fine what'd you have
yeah what have you had to drink just
beer a couple beers you know we we win
today and
we use
canada celebrate what kind of beers are
you drinking
president presidency how many did you
have
like three three four you feel like
you're safe to drive yeah i'm good
i mean you don't need to apologize
all of my friends seriously one of my
friends is around it so what what were
you coming here for this place is closed
no we we're going
well what i'm going to do is make sure
all right hey
what's your name
hey my name is ozuna i know i see that
but listen man i'm just making sure
you're psyched to drop if if we if we
are not african right i'm going like
this with my friends all right just let
me talk to you for a second huh yeah
it's okay okay
is there any reason you were speeding on
this road
i had to get up to over 80 to catch up
to you hey look look you know what
the the light is about to like like
yellow i pass you way back towards the
other end and how to turn around yes
that's what i'm saying you're moving i'm
sorry all right do me a favor real quick
same with your feet together like this
all right hands by your side all right
yeah
can you see the tip of this pin yeah the
blue light right yeah all i want you to
do is follow this with your eyes okay
leave your head still all right you
understand yeah
watch the blue light yeah i saw it you
can see it yeah i saw it all right leave
your head still yeah i saw it
watch the light man i saw the light
i saw the light
i saw the light listen look at the light
don't look at all right look at that
light yes sir yeah do you see the blue
light yeah go ahead okay
don't move your head just follow with
your eyes
okay
radio 116 units it goes forward
10.
all right you good you press your eyes
alright listen there's a few more tests
i want to put you through all right
one it's called the walking turn i know
i know i
yeah all right there's an additional
test called the walking turn and then
one leg saying
you find going through those yeah okay
let's go right over here
you see this painted white line yeah all
right all i want you to do is stand over
here
on this end of it face this way all
right
all right
do you have any problems with your knees
back legs nothing good okay no injuries
i know listen
i know man just listen what i'm asking
you to do okay
on that white line i want you to put
your left foot on the line okay you can
do that now with your right foot over
your left foot touching heel to toe in
this position all right hands by your
side all right you're going to remain in
that position until i tell you to start
you're going to hold that position right
there until i tell you to start i'm
going to explain the test and i'll i'll
tell you what to do okay
yep watch me
you're gonna take a total of nine heel
to toe steps on this line
with your hands by your side you're
gonna look down and count each step out
loud i'm gonna take three steps for
demonstration purposes but you're gonna
take nine all right okay watch me
one two
when you get to your final step you'll
leave that foot on the line with your
opposite foot you take a series of small
steps
and take nine more heel to toe steps
yes sir the opposite direction now
remember while you're doing this look
down at your feet count your steps out
loud
keep your hands by your sides eight nine
and then back yeah when you get to your
next step and once you start don't stop
until you're finished okay okay do you
understand
yeah all right if you understand sir you
can begin you tell me when i finish i'm
gonna be like this and then
hold on all right go back go back to i'm
gonna explain it again okay
so put your left foot on that line yeah
right foot over your left foot okay yeah
just hold that position all right don't
move i'm gonna explain the test you're
gonna take nine steps okay nine heel to
toe steps i'm gonna take three steps
just to demonstrate
one
two
when you get to your ninth step okay
you'll leave that foot on the line with
your opposite foot
take a series of small steps do the
opposite voice yes sir go around it's
like with my rifle yep so once you get
to that right listen it's easy when you
get to that last step yeah you'll leave
that foot on the line and then your
other foot
take a series of small steps just like
this and then you'll go the other way
nine steps okay okay you understand yeah
all right you can begin
144
fun
all right you face me again all right
this next test called the one leg stand
stand your feet together again hands by
your side all right how do i do harder
here do what now you have to you tell me
i have to order here no just listen
feet together again yeah your hands by
your side you can lift either foot okay
of your choice right or left i'm gonna
lift up my left foot
you're gonna hold it approximately six
inches from the ground look down at your
raised foot
hands by your siding you're gonna count
out loud one thousand one one thousand
two one thousand three all right and
keep counting okay until i tell you to
stop okay hold on hold on and do you
understand yeah all right i'll let you
know when to start okay okay okay
you can begin
1001 1002
one thousand four one thousand five one
thousand six four thousand seven one
thousand eight one thousand nine one
thousand then one thousand eleven one
thousand twelve
one thousand thirteen what does the
fourteen what does indeed what does
existing
1017 1018
world does nineteen what doesn't do any
all right you're good you can stop all
right let's walk right back over here
for a second all right staying at the
front of my car yeah
all right hey marcel real quick man this
next one all i want you to do is seal
your lips around this tube take a deep
breath make it like wow they cannot do
that watch that if if if if you want to
make me in jail maybe you okay so you
don't want to i don't want to do that
okay
i do
honestly face my car put your hands
behind your back pull me all right
you're under arrest for dui
no no no no no no no no no i'm gonna
stop that's good put your hands on your
back okay well what do you say oh that's
my car
myself excuse me face my car hey it the
chains punch your back
fix
all right wait right there man don't
move
hey i'm about to do is uh search your
pockets okay make sure you don't have
anything dangerous
do you want your friend to try to drive
your car has he been drinking too
somebody coming
all right that's my car
yeah i don't want to have to tow it you
got someone to come get it that's
perfectly fine all right
oh man you got a lot of cash on you
don't you yeah
oh listen
i know robert bro
i know i know i rover i use i use babel
for i was famous bro i understand man
i'm saying you got a lot of cash in a
second i'm just gonna take it out and
kill it and i'll put it back in your
pocket hey face the car
you know
bam bro you remember
spread your feet for me widen your
stance there you go
all right
before i count the money can you give me
an estimate of how much you
think you have on that
eight thousand or nine thousand eight
thousand oh one chance yeah all right
i'm just gonna count it i'm gonna give
it right back to you all right just
gonna pause
i don't even know listen do you want me
to give listen to me please let's see
do you want me to give the money to your
mom
please
please don't listen don't let it point
for
well you shouldn't have been driving
that's the concern all right yeah listen
to what i'm telling you that's what i
said you're under arrest you're gonna
have to post bond
you've got a lot of money right here
listen i don't know let me ask you can
you tell me i don't want to be
investigators listen tell me do you want
me to
do you want to keep this money or do you
want to turn it over to your mom no i
want i want to give him i want to give
my money to my to my to my guy your guy
where's your guy at
whoever you want to release to that's
fine he's in the car okay you want him
to have all the money or do you want to
hold any of it no
okay
just make sure that's all right can you
tell me the guy's name so i'll make sure
i've released to the right person
i don't want any of this to come up miss
man i'm just keeping it all together all
right who do you want me to release the
money to
i'm gonna give it home what's his name
sandy
this gentleman right here yeah you gave
it all to him all right
he wants to take all the money okay
yeah
you've been drinking anything
okay
you're gonna thank you
you want to take either of them yeah
give them both of them
phone yes sir so again
listen you're gonna have a preset bomb
once you get down there and you can post
the bond all right
all right what's the number all right so
can i get a chance to call in one one
time oh no
what do you mean can i get calling
my my my lawyer right now so right now
so he can he can be he can be around for
tomorrow beyond right away that's fine
i'll let you make a phone call um you
want me to take a number down
my face
foreign
a
want to make a phone call right now yeah
that's fine
units
gross winner okay
okay
so
i have i have the hands crossed
the handcuff
i have a handcuff and then i'm gonna be
in jail like
one minute yeah one minute two minutes
can i talk to the officer yeah he's he's
there
can you talk to him who is this my my
lawyer your lawyer hi i got to hold this
home
real quick we got a large crowd starting
together no you're fine come on over
here i'm just going to put you right
here i'm going to talk about it bro you
know what i gotta be i know i don't want
to know
i'm gonna take care of it
go back i'm gonna put you in the car
all right this is your lawyer you said
yeah okay i don't know
i don't know
you bro
do you want to say anything else to him
because right now i don't have anything
i mean i'm not going to talk to him
right now on the phone but if you want
to talk to him real quick you can
he want to talk to you yeah leave me
listen just i need you to just be quiet
and we're going to come get you out
immediately okay okay just don't say
anything else okay
okay thank you okay i'm gonna end the
call um
do you want to keep yes sir do you want
to keep the phone or you want to give it
back if if
i can use it in the year well you can't
use it but if you need to get numbers
out of it or anything like that yeah
that's what i need okay yeah number
three i'll bring it up
keep it with us all right slide back for
me man i'm gonna put the seat belt on i
just need to be please we'll pee in just
a minute slide back if you can uh put
your legs in
let's put this belt's gross
yeah he's gonna hold this one we're
gonna take this one with us
marcel real quick man i have to read you
this by law just listen there's gonna be
a question at the end right the state of
georgia has condition your privilege to
drive upon the highs of the state upon
your submission to stay diminished or
chemical tests of your blood breath
urine or other bodily substances for the
purpose of determining if you are under
the influence of alcohol or drugs if you
refuse this testing your georgia
driver's license or a privileged job on
the highs of the state will be suspended
for a minimum period of one year
your refusal to submit to blood or urine
testing may be offered into evidence
against you at trial
if you submit to testing and the results
indicate an alcohol concentration of
0.08 grams or more your georgia driver's
license or privilege to drive on the
highways of the state may be suspended
for a minimum period of one year
after first submitting to the requested
state test you're entitled to additional
chemical tests of your blood breath
urine or other bodily substances
at your own expense and for qualified
personnel if you'll choose it
will you submit to the state administer
chemical test of your breath
so yes or no you agree to the state test
of your breath under implied consent
what do you mean
will you submit to the state diminished
chemical test of your breath
they didn't do it
all right so there's an additional test
do you agree to the additional chemical
test of your breath under implied
consent
speak spanish right yeah spanish
hey hernandez
can you just tell them real quick see if
we can get a yes or no answer from them
appreciate it
[Music]
you can see him right here
okay dui and speeding
and failure to maintain lane for heating
only two is he not drained too much
it's a charge right now okay dui alcohol
speeding and uh to maintain lane
all right
please give me a chance for him please
please i'm about to take him do you have
anything else you want to say to him
he has to post spawn
all right
[Music]
foreign
yeah so he'll have the preset bond um if
y'all want to use a bondsman or pay cash
either way he can get out tonight
[Music]
away
a little bit
yeah i mean either way i say right here
that we don't move the cards
go this way
all right let's walk this way yep
yeah all right listen i don't know you
bro i don't know i'm gonna be honest i
know i understand look you can post
spawn all right yeah all right we're
gonna take the cuffs off and go pee real
quick and we're gonna put them right
back on okay problems okay
all right
you know something worked
god
good
let me throw this away
all right let's walk back over to this
car
grab the seat belt real fast
hey thank y'all
well it's over here
county jail start of miles one eight
four two one one eight four two one one
now